learn how to use react and typescript in
this excellent course from roadside
coder this is the only video that you
will need to start building react apps
with typescript in this video we will
first learn the basics of typescript
from absolute scratch and then learn how
to integrate them in our react.js apps
by building an awesome project
we will see how we can use typescript
with react hooks such as use state use
ref and use reducers
how to pass props from one component to
another by defining prop types of the
component and much much more but wait
what is typescript and how is it
different from javascript
so typescript is a superset of
javascript and is built on top of that
according to typescript's website
typescript is javascript that scales
meaning it's perfect for big projects
and production grid apps plus it saves
you from a lot and i mean a lot of
errors
and most of the apps that you use today
are most likely built using typescript
so here's the project that we are going
to build it's called taskify so this is
basically a to-do list app but much more
advanced so if i go on and type learn
type script
now you can see there are multiple icons
over here first one is for editing icon
so let's say learn type script now and
press enter so you can see the to-do has
been edited and we can also delete the
to do by clicking on this button for
example if i click on this you can see
it has gotten deleted and we can
complete the to do by clicking on this
tick mark or there is another way to
complete the to do
to drag and drop it inside of this
completed tasks section this is an
awesome feature of this app that we can
drag and drop between active tasks and
completed tasks i included both of these
ways to tick mark the to-do's and drag
it to the completed to do so that you
can use whichever suits you the best
also you can notice if i go on and type
anything and press on go button you're
gonna see a button press animation just
like this
and you can see i've included animations
on these to-do's as well when we hover
on them
so this is a really good app for
beginners to learn react with typescript
also if you're interested in more such
tutorials on react.js be sure to check
out my channel which is called roadside
coder recently i've uploaded a
full-fledged month stack chat up
tutorial series on my channel link will
be in the description below so without
any further ado let's get started
[Music]
so i've opened vs code over here and now
let's quickly go to our terminal and
initialize a new react app with
typescript but wait we don't know how to
do that
so let's go to our browser and search
react
type script
and let's click on this link
since we are going to use create react
app we're going to go and click over
here so it's similar to our normal react
app installation we are just supposed to
add this dash dash template type script
after it
so let's go ahead and do that so npx
create
react
app and the name of our app let's say
type script
tutorial
and dash dash
template
type script
and press enter
now what this will do is it's going to
go to npm's repository and it's going to
initialize a new react app with all of
the typescript dependencies and all of
the files are instead of dot js going to
be named ads.tsx so if you go back to
our documentation this is for starting a
new create react app project but if you
have already a project that is up and
running with react and javascript you
can add typescript by installing this
npm install typescript with all of the
types here we go our react app has
initialized now let's quickly switch to
that folder by tapping cd typescript
tutorial or we can go to file open
folder
and then open that folder here we go
let's have a look at the folder
structure so in the src usually we see
we have app.js over here but now we have
app.tsx and index.tsx so let's go on and
start our app by tapping npm start
here we go our app has started
successfully now let's go back to our vs
code and i'm going to remove few of the
files that we don't need so report web
vitals setup test logo svg app.test
and delete
now it's going to complain because it
was using those files somewhere for
example inside of the app.tsx we were
using logo
so let's remove everything inside of
here and let's just type
hello world for now
and inside of the index.tsx we were
using this report web vitals so let's
remove that and let's see
there we go we have hello world written
over here but you can see it's in the
center so let me remove all of the
default styles from app.css
now it's good now what is this type in
typescript so let's go on and understand
the types that typescript provides us so
let's say right over here if i go on and
type let name
equals
push so in javascript what happened was
javascript automatically decides what
the type of this variable is so if we go
on and hover on it we can see the type
is string but in typescript we are
supposed to explicitly define those
types so just go on over here and type
colon and string so this is how you
define the type of the variable so if i
go on and remove this
and if i try to say name equals let's
say five now you're going to see an
error
type number is not assignable to type
string so this is a strict type checking
which helps us in typescript but if you
go on and say push
see no problem now let's go on and
assign
let age
to be a number so
we're gonna assign it a number type
similarly we have a bunch of other types
as well such as boolean object array
tuple undefined null and a lot of them
so just like that let's go on how do we
assign boolean so let's say let is
student and type boolean so this is how
we assign it to be boolean boolean can
be true or false
now what if we want to have a variable
called hobbies
and we want it to contain an array of
hobbies which are basically string so
we're going to type colon string
and so it's going to be an array of
string right so we're just going to add
these braces in front of it now it says
that this variable can only contain an
array of strings if you want it to be an
array of numbers so we can type number
over here
now next type is called tuple now what
is tuple so let's say if i go on and say
roll
so what tuple does is tuple contains a
fixed amount of value and the types that
are defined during the declaration so
let me just go on and type number comma
string
so now what this variable can contain is
it's going to contain one number and one
string
so if i go on and say roll equals
provided both of the numbers so it's
going to have a problem type number is
not assignable to type string so this
has to be a string
so something
yeah there we go it's working absolutely
fine so this is called a tuple now next
is for objects how do we define an
object so there are two ways to define
an object first is
let
person our usual way we can type colon
and object but this is not a recommended
way to do this because an object can
have a lot of properties inside of it
such as if i want person object to have
a name and age so how do we know that
this person object contains all of these
properties so we use something called a
type keyword or an interface keyword now
don't worry i'm going to discuss more
about this type and interface later but
for now an introduction i'm going to
type type and we're going to define the
type of this person object so person now
it's a good practice to keep the first
letter of the types as capital so i'm
going to type type person and instead of
it let me just add a name and h property
so name
is going to be a string and age is going
to be a number
so now let's go on and assign this type
person to this type variable so now this
object is going to contain all of the
properties that are inside of this
person type so if i go on and equals
let's say
name
and give it a name let's just give it
just the name for now now you're gonna
see it's complaining to us that property
age is missing in this type so this as
you can see this type has name property
and age property so we are supposed to
give it both of these properties so if i
go on and give let's say age and save it
you're gonna see
it's working absolutely fine but what if
we want to make this age property as
optional so we're just gonna go over
here and add a question mark so this
means that this property is now optional
now if i go on and remove it from over
here
no problem the app is working absolutely
fine now what if we want to have another
variable that is going to contain an
array of person object
so
if i go on create let what's
so we want it to be an array of this
object so we're just going to go over
here and assign it the type of person
and array so just like we did up over
here if we want it to be an array of the
person object we can just assign it the
type like this so you see how easy it is
to assign types in typescript now let me
remove all of this stuff let me comment
it out for now
now over here what if we want our let's
say age variable to be a number and
string both of these i want it to
contain both number and string so we're
just gonna use something called union in
typescript so for union you're gonna
type this symbol and add
another type to it let's go on and
assign this so let's say age if i'm
assigning a string no problem it's
working fine if i go on and assign a
number yup it's working absolutely fine
all right now let's see if we want to
define a function print
name and what this function does is it
takes a name and it just console logs it
so now we have an error
so it says the name implicitly has an
any type okay no problem it says this
name hasn't any type so let's just
provide it a type of string
now if we go on and assign this print
name
name
then it's going to go and print that
just like this but what is the way to
provide a type to a function how do we
declare a function type so there are two
ways to define a function one let's say
if i go on and say let
print
name
i can provide it the type of function
this this works absolutely fine oh it
says print time already been defined let
me just remove this for now
so this works absolutely fine you can
use this function
type but just like objects there's a
better way to assign a function so what
we can do is we can properly define the
function of how many things it's going
to contain so let's say if it
so it takes the name so it's going to
take a type of name which is going to be
a string and what is it going to return
for in our case it wasn't returning
anything so the return type was void
so this is how you assign the type to a
name now don't worry if you're having
problem understanding all of this stuff
when we go on and create our project
then you are going to understand all of
these things in much much in depth so
just like this void return type this can
have a number return type a string
return type a custom return type just
like this person over here now what if
we want this any of these to have any
value let's say if i want the name to
have any value inside of it not just
restrict it to a string or number or
anything we can give it the any type
so any type doesn't have any restriction
you can literally keep anything inside
of it but is but this is not recommended
because obviously why would we need
typescript if we just want to give this
any type to anything so it's recommended
to give type to each and every variable
in typescript now i said it's not
recommended to use any but instead of
any there's a much better type that you
can use so that type is called unknown
so if i go on and say
person name if you don't know what type
it's going to be so we can go ahead and
type unknown over here and it can also
take any type so this is recommended
instead of any so just like this since
we have defined a function over here and
we don't know what this is going to
return if we don't even know if it's
going to return anything or not so we're
just going to go and type never so what
void does is what's the difference
between void and never is void returns
undefined but never doesn't returns
anything so this is the difference
between void and never i would highly
recommend you to go and have a read on
this documentation so if i if you go on
and search type script oops i made a
typo yeah typescript and just go on this
website typescriptlang.org
and click on this docs over here and
click on this the typescript handbook
yep there is this documentation so in
the basic just go on over here and click
on everyday types so see any and
functions and bunch of other types you
can see over here all of the types that
is defined over here so i would highly
recommend you to go and have a read on
this page i'm gonna include the link to
this page in the description all right
cool now let's get back to this thing i
told you that we're gonna go deep into
this so what is this thing called type
so this type is something called as
elias so allies are of two types one is
type and other is interface so let's go
on and explore both of these so you've
already seen this type called type
person so how do we define this by using
an interface so let me just go on over
here and if we want to define it with
interface just add interface over here
and just remove this equal sign now it's
going to work absolutely same as this
type was working so now now you might be
thinking then what's the point of
including both of these what's the
difference between them so let me tell
you the difference between them so in
type what happens is so let me just
define a type let's say type
x
is going to have let's say
a
which is a string and
b which is number
now if we have created another such type
called type
y now what if we want to use these
properties from type x inside of this
type y
so what we can do is just go on over
here
and add x
and
so what this will do is it's going to
contain all of these properties and all
of this property as well so if i go on
and let
y equals and y and assign this this y
type
and inside of it if i go on and add
c which is a string
so something let me just add something
for now
d which is a number
so you're going to see it's complaining
that it is that it is missing some
values a comma b but if i remove this
then it's going to be working absolutely
fine see so in this case we are supposed
to provide it these values this a and b
so type can be extended like this but
how do we do this in the case of an
interface
so let me just
go on over here and type interface
that's a guy
profession which is going to be a string
oops i'm missing a t over here yep so
what if we want to extend person in this
guy interface so it's easier than type
so we're just going to type extends
person
so what i personally do is i like to use
interface a lot so it makes things a lot
easier it helps you and extend it easily
so if you're aware of classes in
javascript so we have classes like this
how you can provide the type to our
classes by using the interface so
class name extends
this interface person but let's just not
get into it for now it's not helpful
right now for us so what if this person
interface wants to extend the type so
let me just remove
these now we can extend these both as
well if you want to have the properties
of person inside of the x we're just
going to do person
and
it's going to work absolutely fine now
if we want to do vice versa
that if you want to have the properties
of x inside of the person
then we can do extends
x
and it's going to work absolutely fine
so this is how this works
so let me remove all of this now
now all of the basics of typescript out
of the way it's time to start building
our react app and understand how we use
typescript with react state react hooks
props etc so one thing that i forgot to
mention that this app is divided into
two parts in this video i will explain
you whole react and typescript part of
this app and in our next video we are
going to implement the drag and drop in
this video we are going to create this
app so let's say
and some others as well
yeah so in this video we're gonna build
this simplified version of this app so
that if you are only here to understand
the react type script part you're not
going to have to waste your time and in
our next video we are going to implement
that drag and drop feature that i showed
you earlier in the intro video other
than drag and drop it's absolutely same
you can edit them as well you can mark
them as completed and stuff like that so
let's go on and build this app so i'm
going to dock it to the side now let me
first convert this function into an
arrow function
so to define the type of this component
first let me just hover on it you can
see it
tells us the type definition of this
component that this is a function that
returns us jsx.element so this is
jsx.element that is returned by this
function but what is this function all
about what is the exact type of this
function so this is a functional
component right so we're just going to
go over here and colon
react dot fc so this is a functional
component so we are providing it the
type of this react dot fc
now there are a bunch of other types as
well
so if you go on and click ctrl space and
you're going to see there are a lot of
types so one of the those types is react
node so this supports all of the types
so this can be boolean this can be react
dot react child react fragment react
portal null undefined and all of these
stuff but since we want it to be a
functional component so we're going to
type react fc now let's go inside of it
instead of this i'm going to type span
and give this a class name of heading
and inside of it i'm gonna write taskify
which is going to be the name of our app
there we go let's give this thing some
basic styles so if i go on inside of
app.css i'm going to import a google
font called neutra let's go to google
and type neutra
font here it is
and just quick just click on select this
style and click on import and take this
font
and paste it over here so let's first
give our app
tag some styles
so i'm just going to bring the styles in
for app and heading because i don't want
to waste time writing css because this
is a typescript tutorial not css
tutorial so there we go what this is
just nothing this is the generic styles
i'm just giving it some width and height
of 100 viewport with 100 viewport height
some display flex and flex direction
column so that all of the things inside
of it are aligned from top to bottom
align items to be the center and
background color is going to be this
bluish color font family is the one that
we have imported just a minute ago for
heading we are going to give transform
text uppercase font size of 40 pixels
some margin some color and z index is
going to be once because we always want
it to be on the top now you're going to
understand why i provided it in just a
minute
when i provide this the animation so
that this doesn't get faded away in the
back it appears always on the top so
that's we're going to care about that
later and some text aligned to be the
center and i'm just going to give it
some media query as well
that is when it's smaller than 800
pixels what's going to happen is the
margin of top and bottom is going to be
15 pixels instead of 30 pixels and font
size is going to be 35 pixels that's all
cool let's move forward
go to app.esx and create our input field
that is this thing this input field so
below this span
i'm going to create a new component
called input field
now obviously this component doesn't
exist yet so let's create a new folder
called
components and inside of it i'm going to
create a new component called input
field dot tsx
r-a-f-c-e
now if you don't know how i did this i'm
using an extension called es7 react
redux
something like that yep this this is the
one so you can download it and you can
type rfc and it's going to generate this
boilerplate so i'm just going to type
for now input over here
and import it by tapping ctrl space over
here and it's going to auto import this
yeah there we go
now let's start building this thing so
inside of this div
and you know what i'm just going to have
a form over here since it's going to be
a form so instead of form
and let's say the form is going to have
a class
and inside of this i'm going to have an
input tag so input
it's going to be of type input
placeholder is going to say enter
a task
and yep just like that it's beginning to
take shape
and we're going to have a class name
okay
of input box
so now if you don't know what this
naming pattern that i'm following is
this is called bem convention of writing
css class names you can just google it
and read more about it it's not
important right now but this is bam
convention of writing css class name you
can ignore it if you want and give your
own class names and now below this i'm
going to have a button
which is going to say go
and it's going to have a class name
of
and type of submit
yeah there we go now let's style both of
these real quick
i'm going to create a css file over here
called styles.css
and import that file inside of it
so import styles dot css
and inside of this styles.css i'm gonna
add
the classes so let me explain you one by
one so first of all for the parent tag
the input tag i'm going to have a
display flex and width is going to be 90
currently
uh i haven't given the weight to this
input box
that's why this is not working but i'm
going to give it real soon i'm giving it
position of relative because we are
going to make this button inside of this
we are going to position this button
inside of it this input box right so we
are going to give this an absolute
positioning that's why we are giving the
parent container as relative positioning
and align items to be the center now for
input box
just like this with is going to be the
hundred percent border radius some
border radius some padding on top left
top bottom and left right some font size
some border you can see just these are
just generic styles some transition so
that our animations looks smooth because
we are adding the animation over here
you can see the button animation
now below this we are going to add some
focus classes so whenever we click on
this whole screen goes
dark and only this appears properly
so if i go and click on this you can see
now what does this inside box shadow
mean so you can see over here there's
box shadow inside of this con this input
box so this insert is for that
and when we focus on this
what's going to happen is it's going to
provide box shadow outside of all of the
outside part of this input box so this
is what it's happening so focus is
focused class is used when we click on
this input box
so this is just basic css now for our
button that is input dot submit we're
going to provide this class so
position is going to be absolute oops i
think
single colon so
yep single colon yep just like that so
currently the animations are not working
but i'm gonna make them work in just a
minute so position is going to be
absolute because if we don't do this see
what's gonna happen it's going to be
outside of it so we want it to be
position inside
and right is going to be zero so that it
we want it to be an absolute right side
some width and height some margin some
border radius what is going to be none
some font size background color and just
generic style some little bit of box
shadow that you can see over here below
this so that's all
now let's provide it the animation so
when we hover on it first of all what's
gonna happen is
you can see it glows up
so let's provide the hover class to it
there we go you can see background color
gets a little bit brighter
and when it's active that is when we
click on it we want
an animation to happen so transform is
going to be scale 0.8 we want it to
become a little bit smaller see just
like this and box shadow is going to be
a little bit smaller as well from 10
pixel to 5 pixels so that it gives us
some depth effect now let's come to our
main functionality of our app that is
creating the state for our to do so
inside of app.tsx
let's create our first state so i'm
going to type use state
and let's give this state the name of to
do
and it's going to have an initial value
of empty
let's import the use state yup just like
that now we are supposed to give this
state a type since we are using
typescript so we are give supposed to
give this a type right so since we have
given this an empty string let's see
what this type is
this is the type of string so we are
supposed to give this a type of string
if we remove this
and hover on this you can see the type
is now undefined because it doesn't know
what the type is but we are supposed to
give this the type of string because our
to do will be of the type string right
so type string and let me just give it
some initial value of empty so this is
how you define the string by using these
brackets these pointed brackets over
here now what if you want to accept
multiple types of value inside of it so
just like i explained earlier we can use
union over here and give this number
and just like this it's going to be
working absolutely fine so the rules
that i explained you earlier in the
video all of the rules apply over here
as well if you want to be array
you can add this like this very cool now
let's just provide this to do and set to
do to our input field component
so just like normal react to do
just like this we are going to give it
but now it's going to give us an error
because it says property to do does not
exist on this
component so we are supposed to make it
exist on this component so let's go to
over here
and let's try to accept it to do
comma set
to do
it's still going to give us here binding
element to do implicitly has an any type
so it this thing has an any type so we
are supposed to define the type to this
so we can just go on over here outside
these brackets and colon and provide
these the types so to do is going to
have a type and set to do is going to
have a type so let me just instead of
writing it over here i'm just going to
create it
right over here so i'm just going to
create an interface that i explained you
earlier so interface let's say props
so props is going to have value of to do
and set to do so we know to do what what
is to do it's string right easy
but what is set to do
because set to do is a function right so
how do we know what set to do is type is
so let's go back to app.tsx and it's
easy to know that if you go on and hover
on this
you're gonna see this thing written over
here react or dispatch now you might not
be able to understand what this exactly
is so just go on and copy this up and
paste it over here
and now you're gonna see that we haven't
provided it this types so props
yep now it's going to work fine yep
there we go our app is working
absolutely fine so this is this is just
basically the type of this set to do you
don't need to understand all of this
this is just basically the typo you can
just take these from hovering on to this
awesome so i hope you are having the
gist of how we use this stuff now
instead of defining the props over here
what you can do is you can also give
these like this so
as i told you already this is a
functional component so react dot fc
and in front of it we can provide these
props
just like this
whatever you find easier you can use it
so this thing is basically not that much
necessary because it already knows that
this is a functional component now let's
simply go to our input tag and give it a
value of to do
and on change it's going to change our
to-do state
i'm going to take an event
e dot target dot
value
now call let's try to do console log
over here and see if it's working to do
go to ins
something yep it's working fine great
now that to do that we are going to
create is going to have a few properties
inside of it first property is going to
have a unique id so if i go on over here
and create a to do over here so this to
do has many properties it has first this
to do property which contains this text
inside of it other one is going to be a
unique id and the third one is going to
be is done variable so is done means if
it's done or not if it's completed or
not so this is going to be keeping the
track of that thing
so let's go on and create a model for
our to do because we are going to use
this to do at a lot of places so let's
just create it separately so i'm going
to create a new file called model
dot ts
dot ts not tsx because it's going could
be normal typescript file so inside of
it i'm going to create an interface
called to do and it's going to have the
properties that i mentioned called id
which is going to be number obviously a
to do property which is going to be a
string
and a is done property which is going to
be
boolean
great now we want to use it somewhere
else so let's just export this thing so
export interface yep great now we're
going to create another state which will
contain all of our to do so we are
constantly entering our to-do's over
here so this has to be inside of a
particular state right so use state
and let's name this to do's and it's
going to be an empty array now you might
be thinking how are we going to provide
this the type so what type is it going
to be because it's going to be an array
of to-do's so we are going to import the
model that we have created to do
here we go it has been imported so to do
and it's going to be an array so
we're going to make it an array
so this is how you create an array of a
type or an interface awesome
now let's try to create a handle add
function which will add the to-do's to
this state so let's go back to our app
and i'm gonna create a new function over
here const
handle add it's going to take something
inside of it and it's going to return so
this is a function over here now it's
going to take an event from on submit so
right over here from whenever we submit
the form it should add this inside of
our
handle add now let's take this function
and pass this to our input field
and it should give us an error because
this function doesn't exist yep there we
go
now we what we are supposed to do we are
supposed to add this function over here
in these props
so handle add what is this function
going to be
so just like i taught you earlier we are
supposed to define a function just like
this so since this function is not going
to return anything so i'm just going to
write it like this function and it
returns nothing
so let's receive it over here yep just
like that
now what are we going to do when
whenever we click on this go button so
whenever we press submit this this
function should fire off so on
submit
we have to fire up this handle add
function
great
now one thing you will notice whenever
you press press on go you can see the
page refreshes to so to avoid that what
we do is
we go to in a normal javascript what we
do is we just go to this function and we
take an event variable over here and
just write even dot
prevent
default
right but it's but it's gonna give us
this error e implicitly has an any type
so we are supposed to provide this a
type
so let's go on google and type
event type in react
type script so i'm just trying to show
you over here what you need to do
whenever you get stuck in a particular
thing in react type script
so let's go on over here
and you can see it has given us this
type react change event html input
element so we can take this but there is
a better type instead of this let's
search it react dot synthetic event or
there's one more type called react dot
form event that we can use yep there we
go react dot form event
so all of these these are going to work
so but i'm just explaining you the best
that you should use
react dot form event now it's not going
to give us any error okay so it's giving
us error because we haven't set this
type over there over into our props
right over here so we are supposed to
define this over here as well because we
are supposed to define it everywhere we
are sending this variable so great
that's awesome now whenever we click on
this handle add what should happen is it
should set our state it should set our
to-do's
so
set to do's to be what first of all
we're gonna check if there's something
inside of the to do
then only just we are supposed to set
the to do right
so set to do and
take whatever that is already inside of
the to do's of this variable and we are
going to add another to do so comma
what was the three fields first was id
so we're going to generate and random id
for that let's just type date dot now so
this is going to generate a random id
for this
so now you can see as soon as i save
it's going to complain is missing the
following properties to do
and is done so let's just add them
comma to do
to do is going to be to do
and is done
and obviously it's just created so it's
not done so i'm just going to give this
by default false oops i write data over
here so date dot no yeah so instead of
writing this to do colon to do we can
just write to do since
these both are same name awesome that's
fine it's working fine and now what
after this after the to do has been
created what we are supposed to do we
are supposed to empty this input field
right so set
to do is going to be empty
all right cool let's try this out i'm
gonna do console log so i'm gonna
console.log to do's okay
let's go to in
inspect cons
if i click on go yup there we go it has
generated this array and and emptied
that
yep there we go if we go on over here
yeah it has created both of these to do
with some random id is done and false
awesome now let's go on and render all
of these to do in form of this
component this card type of component
so i'm gonna go over here and create a
new component called to do
list
now we are supposed to create this to-do
list component
but before we do this i forgot to do one
thing so if we go on inside of the input
field there's one problem over here
so if we go on and type and press enter
so you can see
it maintains this shadow state so if we
go on again and press enter so it's
maintaining this shadow state so what's
the solution for this whenever we press
enter it should get rid of this
background shadow so for that we are
going to use a react hook called use ref
so let's see how we use use ref with
typescript first of all we are supposed
to add it in handle submit so let me
just write handle submit like this
for now let me just render all of those
to-do's over here
dot map so that we can see all of them
so like
you can see all of these to do us
to-do's are beginning to appear over
here
great
now if we go on over here we are going
to create a use ref so if you don't know
what user f is user f is basically like
when we use document.getelement by class
name or
document.getelementbyid we are hooking
that particular components html so just
go on over here and type use ref and i'm
going to name this ref as input ref and
the initial value is going to be null
let's import this ref
just like that and we are going to
provide this ref to our input tag so ref
equals
input ref so this is how it works but
how are we supposed to give this ref a
type now what is going to be the type of
this input tag so it's very easy just go
on over here and hover on it and you're
gonna see some
bunch of crap written over here which no
one understands
so what we are going to do we are just
going to take this thing html input
element so this is what we need so if we
want to identify the type of this form
this is the type of the form html form
element so this is a pattern actually so
if we are supposed to write for div it's
html div element so for input it's html
input element
so let's take this
and just like use ref we are going to
add it inside of these brackets over
here so html input element now it knows
that this is an html input element so
what we are going to do to get rid of
this
blur whenever we press enter
so on submit it's just going to perform
this handle add and what else it's going
to do it's going to take this input ref
input ref now i'm going to show you
what's the advantage of adding a type
over here so input ref dot it's it has a
object called current so it's showing us
this current dot now you're gonna see we
have all of the function that we can
perform on this thing on this input
object
so we have a function called blur over
here so we're gonna use blur so what
blur does this it shifts the focus from
this input box we have added the blur
over here and you can see it has already
added automatically added this question
mark because it's not sure if it's going
to be optional or if it's going to have
be having any value inside of it so yep
let's go ahead and try it out if you
type anything and press enter yeah there
we go it has got rid of that blur so
this is how we use use ref hook with
typescript let's go back to our app.tsx
and
we are going to create a to-do list
component let's go inside of our
component and create a new file called
to do
list dot
dsx r a f c e just like that it's going
to be a react
oops react dot functional component
and let's import this thing first
there we go it has imported
now let's go inside of this to-do list
component and create this so inside of
this div first of all i'm going to give
this div a class name
of to-dos
and let's import our style sheet as well
so
import
dot slash styles dot css inside of this
to do div
i'm gonna map through it map through all
the to do's but wait we don't have the
to do's over here so we are supposed to
bring them in
so we are supposed to bring in to do's
and set to do's as well
because we are going to delete them from
this component so we are going to delete
them and mark them as complete so we are
going to need set to do's as well so set
to do's now it's going to obviously
going to complain because we haven't
defined the
you know the type of these to do's and
set to do's so let's define this over
here
and face
props to do's
so what to do was it was an array of the
type to do so let's import to do first
yep just like that and it was an area of
to do's great
now next thing was set to do's now again
we don't know how do we define this
thing so let's just go to app.esx and
hover on this
and let's just take this thing
and bring it over here yep that's
absolutely fine
oh okay we haven't assigned it i always
forgo forget to assign props and let's
refresh it yep it's fine it just says we
haven't imported it right oh okay so it
says that we haven't uh in provided it
this to do's and set to do's so let's
just provide it real quick
to do's
to do's
see this is what i like about typescript
it clearly tells you what is going wrong
in js you might be wondering oh okay
what's going on why it's giving error so
set to do it's clearly showing you that
what you are supposed to do next in your
application
so let's go back to our to-do list app
yeah and let's start to map all of those
do's
single to two
and let's instead of it let's just
create all of this you know of the card
component let's create a separate
component for this card itself so i'm to
create a separate component called
single to do so for now let me just uh
let me just add a list over here
to see if it's working fine or not to do
dot to do
so if you just remove it and see
by having dot you can see we have three
properties id is done and to do so we
need to do from over here let me provide
this to do a little bit of styling
so instead of styles.css i'm going to
add this to do so it's going to be
display flex just like this so it
appears in a similar line and when there
are more than one to do it's just wraps
into another line
so it's not going to work now because we
haven't created those card component so
display flags justify content space
evenly so that there's space between
them weighs 90 percent and flex wrap of
wrap so let's go on and create that
single to-do component
instead of this so let's create a new
component called single
to do
dot t s x
r a f c e
just like that now if we go back to our
app you can see we have few icons over
here for example this edit icon this
delete icon and this tick mark or
complete icon so for this we are using a
library called
react
oops react
icons so if you google search react
icons you're gonna find this result over
here and let's just install this library
npm install react icons i'm going to
open another terminal and install it
now meanwhile this is installing let's
go to react icons and search an edit
icon
so you can see this is the edit icon
that we are going to use
let's search a delete icon
this is the delete icons just like that
a tick
or done maybe
yeah there we go this is the done icon
so this is what we are going to use
here we go the react icons have
installed successfully let's continue
building our app so what are the things
that we are going to send to this single
to do component
so let's go to our to-do list and first
of all import this over here
single to-do yep just like that so we're
gonna send it this to do obviously so
to do
and since we are mapping it so we are
gonna provide it the key to do dot id
and we're gonna send it all of the to
do's so to do's
so
all of the to do's are going to be
needed for deleting the stuff and
editing the stuff stuff like that
so to do
now it's going to give us the error
because we haven't set the props yet
obviously so
yep just like that and now we have to
deal with some errors i believe
yep there we go over here first let me
receive all of those things so to do
comma to do's
comma set
to do's
and over here let's define an interface
or you know what let's just define a
type so that you can get the hang of
both of these things props
and as you know in the interface we
don't write this equal sign but in type
we do
so first of all that to do what's going
to be the type of to-do
the model that we created
now second to do's that we are sending
so what's going to be the type of
to-do's it's going to be then array of
to-do's
and then the third
set to do's
it's going to be the type that we copied
over here just like this
there we go now it shouldn't be a
problem and let's define it over here
just like that
yeah it's working fine all right let's
start building our single to component
so this is also going to be a form
because we are going to add the edit
functionality you're going to know why i
made this a form
when i create the edit functionality
and instead of this i have a span with
the class name of
to do's
single text
so this is basically going to display
the to do to do dot to do
let's see if this works or not if i go
on and press enter yep it's displaying
that to do
now below this
below this we're gonna have our div
inside that div we're gonna create all
of this stuff
this uh all of these icons first icon
and we're gonna keep them inside of the
span tag so let's give them the class
name of icon
so i have three icons so
first one will be
fill edit text so ai fill edit so how do
we use this if i go on and click on this
yeah so if i go on over here and paste
it
now i'm gonna tell you how you can use
react icons so you need to
pay attention over here what is written
at the first two letters so this is ai
type of
icon so there are many type of icon let
me show you import
from icons so if we go and press slash
we are there are a bunch of types of
icon like aibi bs cg so we need ai right
so click on
just like that and just take this and
import it from over there save this it
should work if i'm not wrong um
yeah there we go it has generated this
edit icon so just like that what we need
is
ai fill delete and ai third one was
something else i believe let see
so let's take that and
comma
yep there's that's that and the third
one was md done so you can just go on
and just search it over here
and this is the one md done
so
amd done and now you're supposed to
import it from the md
so
just replicate it
md done from
md yeah
yeah it has all of those three icons
awesome let's go on and style these
so i'm gonna import our style sheet over
here
go inside of the styles first of all for
our todos dot single that is this style
it's going to have display of flex and
width is going to be 29.5 in a normal
screen but when we make this
response so you can see it doesn't look
good right now so it it i'll make it
better in the responsive so when the
screen size is less than 800 pixels i'm
gonna make it full size
so i'm just gonna do that just in a
minute so after that
border radius is going to be five pixel
padding is going to be 20 pixels inside
of it and margin top is going to be
having 15 pixel as you can see so that
it maintains a little bit of gapping and
some background image so you can take
this background image from the get
repository so we are going to find the
git repository
just go to github.com
push dash eon
inside the repository
now search over here typescript
so you can see react typescript taskify
just go on over here and this is
important you just click on over here
and click on this react typescript
tutorial branch so all of the code that
i'm teaching in this tutorial it's going
to be inside of the react type script
tutorial branch so you can go to src
components
styles
and the link is right over here you can
take the link of this picture or you can
add your own picture just like you want
yeah so next to do single dot text now
we are styling our text a little bit
this text so flex one
means that it's going to take all of the
available space and it's going to push
all of the content to the other side of
this box
border is going to be none font size is
going to be 20 pixels and now this is
going to be used when we make it an
input box so right now you don't need to
pay attention to this so icon yep all of
these icons are going to have margin
left of 10 pixels font size of 25 pixels
and cursor is going to be pointer so
that you can see our cursor because
becomes a pointer let me quickly add the
responsiveness to it
for our input box
is going to be having width of 95
percent when the screen size is less
than 700 pixels to do's are going to be
having width of 95 percent that is this
and to do single is going to be having
without hundred percent that is the
single component and to do this is going
to be the 100 i mean the whole list
right so if i save this see it looks
good now in the bigger screens the width
is going to be 40 for this single to do
component so yeah that's all all right
now let's try to enter more to do's
awesome so and if we go on smaller
screen yep it's perfectly responsive
but now it you can see this is not
working because we haven't created the
functionality for them yet for the edit
delete and done
so let's go on and do that first of all
i'm gonna add the functionality for done
so on md done span i'm gonna add an on
click function and what it's going to do
it's going to fire off
a
handle
done function and it's going to
send it its id to do id so this handle
done doesn't exist yet so let's go on
and create it
const handle done
just like this and you can see it says
that you are sending this to dot id but
you are not receiving it over there so
let's receive it over there so we are
going to receive the id over here and
this id is going to be of type number
so now what are we going to do with this
id we're going to manipulate our set to
do's state with the help of this id so
todos
dot map
so what are we going to do we are going
to map through this array and whichever
id matches with this id we're going to
make the is done property of that from
false to true and vice versa so we're
going to take to do
and
we're going to say if to do
dot id
matches
oops if to do dot id
is equal to the id that we are sending
then what are we supposed to do
we're going to take that to do all of
the properties and we're gonna change
the is done property so comma
is done and we're gonna invert the value
that was already there so
invert to do dot is
done otherwise we're just gonna return
the to-do
just like that
oh i forgot to wrap all of this stuff
in the map so yeah now it's working fine
the spelling mistake over here is done
yeah now it's working fine now if you go
on and click over here it's gonna
make it disabled but you obviously you
can't see it right now because we
haven't implemented it so what we are
going to do we are going to check it
over here if this is completed then just
strike it off go on over here
and we're going to check so to do
the current to do dot is done if it is
done
then it's going to strike it off
otherwise it's going to render the
normal one
so it's going to render the normal one
over here
otherwise it's going to instead of span
just s that is strike tag
so you can see it has been done if i
click again over here it's not done yeah
just like that now let's go on and
implement the delete functionality
so i'm gonna go over here and let's copy
this up
just like this i'm gonna add it over
here and instead of handle done we're
gonna add handle delete
let's create the handle delete function
right below this const handle delete
and just like that it's going to take
the id
which is going to be a number
now it's fairly simple we're just going
to do what we're going to do is filter
so set to do's to do's dot filter
to do
and if to do
dot id
is not equals to id only then returned
so that means if we click on this
instead of this id all of them will be
returned and this one will be deleted so
if i click on this yeah there we go
this is how it works
awesome now
a little complex part we are going to
implement the edit functionality so
let's go on and do that so for that we
are going to create two states first one
will keep the track if the edit mode is
on or not and the second one will keep
the value of the edited to do so use
state
first one will be for edit which will be
true or false so it's going to be
boolean so let's add this
type of boolean
also import use state radia so it has
imported the use state so other one
it's going to keep the edit to do text
so
add it to do so it's going to be string
string
it's going to be empty by default
you know it's not going to be empty
actually it's going to contain this
thing already so
to do
dot to do
it's going to contain the to do dot to
do inside of it so that whenever you
press the edit mode the input text input
box appears with this to-do value
just go on over here for edit on click
what are we gonna do we're gonna check
if
edit mode is on or not so if
edit if edit mode is not on and
to do
dot is if it's not done
so if it's not done so because if it's
already done then what's the point of
editing it so if it's not then only then
we are going to edit it
then set edit
to be the value of
then set edit to close
then we are not supposed to edit it
right oops i forgot to do this
got to create a callback over here
so if it's not done then only we are
supposed to edit it right cool so this
will help us switch between the edit
modes so if i go on and
do this currently it's not going to work
so we have to add a input field over
here and conditional over here so let's
add the conditional
so
i'm gonna say if edit mode is on
edit mode is on then it's going to
display the input box
other than that if it's not on then it's
going to
display the normal that is this part
okay add an input
just like that
what's wrong oh we we are supposed to
remove this thing
yep it's fine
yeah there we go if i click on this
again
let me do this
okay we have not styled it yet so uh
let's just first create it then i'm
gonna style it so first of all the value
is inside of it it's going to be this
thing
this edit to do so what value did we put
inside of it to do dot to do so you're
gonna see as i put this on
yep
it appears so let me refresh this page
and if i click on it yeah you can see it
appears second we're gonna add an
onchange function so on change
we're gonna update this set edit to do
this thing
set edit to do
so and change
let's say event dot target
dot value so add the event over here yep
and it's going to have a class name for
us to style this thing
off to do's
single
text again following the bam convention
over here yep so there we go also
whenever we press on this when so on
change what on change will do it's just
going to update the state but what i
want whenever press whenever i press
enter then it's going to change the
state or it's going to submit it and
change the actual to do
so i'm going to create a handle edit
over here and it's going to be firing
off whenever it's submitted so submit
and
edit
so it's going to take two things first
of all the event and the other thing is
going to be to do dot id
so this hasn't been created yet let's
create it first
const handle edit
two things first the event which will be
of type react dot
form event
and other one will be id which will be
of type number
all right cool so after this has been
submitted what it's going to do
first of all it's going to be preventing
the default behavior so that the screen
doesn't get refreshed
and then we're going to set the to do's
to do's dot map
and
inside of it if the to-do dot id
matches the id that is sent by them
that is sent by the on submit then what
it's going to do it's going to take all
of that to do's
i mean all the to do's properties and
instead of like for example we're just
just like we did it with is done
we're just going to update that to do so
to do will be added
to do
and if it doesn't matches it's just
going to return this to do that's all
and after this
it's going to set
edit
to false
just like that so let's go on and try
this if i go and try hello and press
enter yep you can see it has been edited
hello world
uh presenter yep it's the editing is
working absolutely fine so let's first
style this so that it doesn't look ugly
also if you remember i set this over
here
um
this thing outline then if i remove this
you're going to see if i click on this
you're going to see this ugly outline
over here so if i remove this you're not
gonna see this outline over here
oh so it was text and that i have okay
okay
i've written this test over here yeah
now it should work yep there we go so
yeah i guess it's working absolutely
fine but you know there are there's one
flaw that i just noticed if we click on
this edit button you can see the focus
does not go inside of this input
component we have to manually click over
here and then type it so let's just take
care of that so we're just going to
again use
make the use of use ref hook
so
use ref
and i'm going to name it input ref
you can name it anything doesn't really
matter and just like we did earlier
first of all let me import this
and just like we did earlier let's take
this thing
ready to go
yeah
html input element
yeah and provide this ref
equals input ref and we're going to
create a use effect over here
which
whenever the edit changes it's going to
fire off this that means it's going to
what it's going to do so let me show you
input ref first of all let me put input
ref above this one
yeah so input ref dot
current dot
focus so it's going to focus on that
thing
whenever this changes so if i go and
press edit yep you can see the focus is
already inside of this
yup it's working fine cool
so our to-do list app has been
successfully completed but there's one
more thing left that i need to explain
you that is use reducer hook so for
explaining use reducer hook
now if you don't know what use reducer
hook is i've created a full video on
this my previous video was on reuse
reducer hook i've taught how you can
create a shopping cart app by using user
edition hook so you can go on and watch
that video link will be in the
description or i button above so but if
you already know let's go on and
understand how we can use the type
script with user user hook so instead of
this models.tsx i'm just going to
explain you so this is going to be a
homework to you i'm going to explain you
use reducer hook and your job will be to
implement it inside of this project so
let's say if we have created a component
over here let me create a dummy
component
and inside of it we're going to create a
reducer by using use reducer and as i
told you in the previous video what we
do in user editor we provided an initial
value so we provide this initial value
first of all let me just import it
just like this so let's bring it down
over here yeah we can import it like
this
and now we're going to provide it a
reducer
so let's say to do
reducer
and it's going to return us the state
and dispatch
now let's create this to do reducer
so const to do reducer
now what do the reducer take it takes a
state and it takes the actions so we
need to provide the types to our state
and action
so let's just first write state comma
action so what is the state going to be
so state is going to be the array of
to-do's right so we can just take this
interface and write
to do
and the array of to do so this is how we
define the state
and what are we going to keep in our
actions so our action are going to have
three things add
the to do remove the to do and done so
it's going to perform three actions so
let's create the type for our action so
type actions
and it's going to first action what is
going to be
so we want them to be one at a time
right either add can be performed or
remove or done can be performed
so we're just gonna write like this
inside the curly braces we're gonna
write type because obviously this action
has two properties right one is type and
other is payload so type is going to be
add
and the payload
is going to be a string because we are
sending something to add something we
are going to send the string from the
input box so this
otherwise what's going to happen is so
let me just write this over here
otherwise let me copy this up
otherwise this is going to happen
it's going to have remove action
and for removing we just need to send
the id
so we're going to type number over here
otherwise
we're going to do done action
and it's going to be number as well
so this is how you define your actions
now just take it and assign it to over
here
just like that okay now let's create
this to do reducer so inside of it we're
going to have a switch case so let me
just bring it in so this is how it
reducer look if you have already worked
on reuse reducer then you're going to
understand how this works it's just to
understand how you can integrate
typescript inside of it so this is just
the add action
we're just adding this action like this
the remove action it's just the things
that i've already done in the project
this is how you create a use reducer
in our react apps so i'm just gonna make
it commented out
so basically what i wanted to explain
you is this actions type and this state
type
so yep so now what i want you to do is i
want you to take this reducer and i want
you to integrate inside of our app and
if you don't know how to do server just
must watch my previous video which is on
user reducer awesome so we have
successfully understood react with
typescript and let's start integrating
the drag and drop in our application so
let's make the suitable ui changes so
that we can go ahead and make it look
like this
so whenever we enter the to do it
appears on active tasks and we should
have a completed task section over here
so let's go and make the changes in this
particular app
so i'm going to go to to do's list
component
and let me remove this div
and i'm going to add another div called
container
and inside of this container dave we're
going to have another div
called to dose
now this to do's div will be for this
particular active tasks and we're going
to create another div for our completed
tasks
so i'm going to take this div and paste
it and let's add another class over here
let's say remove
and inside of both of these we're gonna
add some code we're gonna first of all
add this span tag for the headings so
span dot to do's
underscore underscore
heading
all right and instead of this i'm gonna
write
active tasks
and below this we're gonna take
this to do's state that is being passed
from app.tsx and we're going to
render all of the
to-do's group.map
to do
and again just like previously we are
going to render our single to-do
component over here
so
single to-do
and we are going to pass them pass it to
do
and we need to send to do's
also
great
so this should work now
okay it doesn't look really good right
now so i'm gonna fix that later so let's
copy this up
and i'm gonna paste this inside of our
to do remove as well
yeah that looks ugly so instead of
active tasks i'm gonna write
completed tasks
so right now i'm just rendering this to
do's dot map inside of this but later we
are going to have a separate state for
completed to do's and we're gonna render
that particular state over here now
let's provide it some styling so that it
doesn't look this ugly so go to
style.css and let's start by changing
this width to 95 percent
and come down over here and just below
above this to do's
i'm going to add a container class that
we created the container
and we're going to provide this
container cloud display flex so that it
appears
in one row
so display
flex
some width of 95
and i'm gonna bring in a few styles so
that we don't have to waste time writing
css
we're gonna add some margin top to
create some spacing justify content is
going to be space between so that some
they have some space in between them
just like this some align items to flex
start so that they are aligned to the
very start of the container cool now i'm
going to make some changes to this to do
so
i'm going to remove this
change the width to
47.5 percent because they are taking the
half of the screen right so 47.5 and i'm
going to remove this flex wrap and i'm
going to add i'm going to make them
column so that they appear in one row so
right now if you see they appear side by
side so i'm going to make them flex
direction column some given give them
some padding some border radius of 5
pixel and some background color so let's
see yep that looks pretty good and now
we should make this single to do two
span
whole of this div but first of all let's
provide some to do's heading style so
dot
to do's
heading
it's gonna have some font size of 30
pixels
provided 30 pixels now next for to do
single we need to provide it full width
or maybe we don't need to provide it
anywhere because the display is flex so
it's all automatically going to span it
yep there we go and we are going to add
some transition to it so that when we
hover on this it grows a little bit so
we are going to add that hover as well
but first let me add just transition of
0.2 seconds and let's add those hover
styles just like this so when we hover
on this box shadow will appear of 5
pixels and we're going to scale it to
1.03 so it's going to get a little bit
bigger so see over here
yep this is the animation awesome now
let's come down
now we need to remove
inside of media query i'm going to
remove this we don't need this anymore
because with automatically controlled
but for our to-do's when it's so when
the screen is smaller than 1100 pixels
we're gonna have to do's with the width
of 45 percent
so let's check it out yep just like that
now next inside of here in our to-do's
i'm gonna add some margin bottom so that
it looks a little bit neat in smaller
screens
also we need to remove this with hundred
percent
so that it creates a little bit spacing
and we're gonna add some container
styles to make them from uh top to
bottom so we're gonna provide that
container some flex direction of column
here with width of 95 percent so
currently it's half of it
around 50 percent but we're gonna make
flex direction to be column
yep just like this and also this
completed task should have a background
color of red
so let's add a remove class that we
added it so
background color is going to be red
yep that looks much better cool now i
think our ui is done now let's start
implementing the react beautiful dnd
package into our application so i'm
going to open a new tab and search react
beautiful dnd
let's go to this npm package and here we
go we have the installation instructions
over here and we have some documentation
if you want to go ahead and read this
you can do that so this is how the drag
and drop will work so we're going to
wrap whole of our app with this drag
drop context tag and the place that is
this place where all of our to-do's will
be rendered we're going to wrap it with
dropable and one single to-do will be
wrapped with draggable tag if you're
unable to understand this right now
don't worry i'm gonna explain everything
as we go along let's go to our terminal
and
paste this
npm i react beautiful dnd all right
there we go it's installed let me close
this terminal and let's go to our
app.tsx and i'm going to create a new
state for our completed to-do's so use
state
completed
and it's going to be an empty array to
begin with
and it's going to be of type same to
do's type now if you're coding in
javascript you don't need to worry about
all of these types and stuff you can
directly just create use state like this
now we need to send both of these to our
to-do's list component over here
set completed to do's also this thing
okay so it's giving us error because we
because this doesn't exist in our
to-do's list
so let's go ahead and add this so
completed again you don't need to worry
about all of this if you're coding in
javascript
so it it was of type
to-do's array so we're going to take
this
add it over here and set
completed
to do's
now what how did we
added the type to this we just hover on
this and take this
okay complete it to do's yep
that's fine all right so our app is
working fine till now now how do we add
react beautiful dnd to our app
so we need to go to our app.tsx which we
are already in so we need to wrap this
with something called drag drop context
so drag drop
context
and we're going to wrap whole of our app
inside of this
now we need to import it from react
beautiful dnd
so import
from
react beautiful dnd and just go over
here press ctrl space control space
whoops okay it's not coming oh i got it
we forgot to do one thing we forgot to
install the types for this particular
library so whenever we install few
dependencies in typescript they require
you to install some types for them so
i'm going to click over here
and it's going to take us over here so
we need to copy this line or we can
simply copy this over here
and just go back and open another
terminal and just install these types
because these types are important for
this package to function properly all
right there we go it has installed let
me close this terminal up and now if i
go and press control space and click on
this you're gonna see it has imported
now it says an error so it requires a
prop called on drag and which we are
going to worry about later but don't
need to worry about right now so let's
go to to-do list and inside of our to-do
list component we're gonna wrap it with
something called dropable because this
area right here is a dropable area this
area is also a droppable area so if i
type anything
okay
so this is going to be a draggable thing
and this is going to be a droppable
thing so let's wrap this inside of our
droppable so right below this i'm gonna
add
dropable
and i'm gonna take whole of this div
and push it inside of it
now this droppable is going to have an
id
okay so it's still giving that error on
dragon so let me just add this on dragon
for now just like this
yeah fine so it's it has stopped giving
error for there
there but over here it's giving some
error it requires droppable props so
first of all we need to give this a
droppable id
so droppable id is nothing but to
identify this droppable zone uniquely so
we're gonna provide it let's say to-do's
list
okay and inside of it we can we can just
put it just like this we need to pass a
callback and then we need to shift it
inside of there i'm going to open a
curly brace and inside of a function
you can say we're going to take this div
and paste it
now inside of this function it takes a
few parameters so first one will be
provided and second one i'll talk about
later
so first of all provide it so what is
provided going to do so we're going to
take this provided and provide it to our
parent div of this particular droppable
zone so to the parent day we need to
provide a ref
and ref will have provided dot inner ref
so that react beautiful dnd can control
this as a droppable zone
and also we also need to spread provided
dot droppable props so that is what it
was asking
provided
dot droppable props
yeah that's fine
cool so
but still if you go on over here and do
anything you you're gonna see it's still
not working because we have to do a lot
of things apart from this as well so
let's make this droppable zone as well
just like we did with this thing so i'm
going to copy this up go right over here
and
let's put this div inside of here
and instead of to do's list i'm going to
change its name to to do's
remove
okay now we need to provide it the
function again just like we did with the
previous one so i'm gonna shift whole of
this div
inside of there
just like that
we're gonna take provided
and we're gonna take both of these
things and we need to
provide it to our parent dave
just like this all right cool no error
and still not working
nothing
okay yeah i forgot one thing we passed
this completed to do's so we need this
as well so let me keep them over here
comma
set completed to do's
yup
so when i take this completed to-do's
and replace it with these to do's
so with this this
and instead of this i'm gonna put set
completed to do's yep so now you're
gonna see it's not gonna show anything
even if we add a lot of things over here
okay cool also one more thing i forgot
to do is we need to send the index to
our single to-do's component because
it's going to track which of this
particular to-do is being dragged don't
worry i'm gonna explain it in just a
second so for now just follow along
i'm passing this index as index
you're gonna see how i'm gonna use this
so again it's giving error because
single to do does not exist except index
right now but we're gonna make it accept
it
all right now let's go to single to do's
and
add the type for index
which is going to be a number
and over here as well i'm gonna add
index
great now we need to make this single
to-do's as a draggable thing so
outside of this i'm gonna add a tag
called
draggable
and i'm gonna wrap whole of this form in
this draggable
just like that
and similarly we're going to add the
function inside of this as well but
let's just provide it a draggable id
and we're going to make this drag about
id so that it it should be unique right
so i'm just going to provide the id of
the to do's to this
so to do dot id
dot 2 string and i'm going to provide it
the index so that it keeps the trap of
track of index so this is the same index
that we brought from the to do's list
component
and now inside of it let's add our
function
take the form
and put it inside of it
just like this you can see we put the
form inside of this
now again we need to take provided so
you see this is just a similar kind of
stuff we just have to set up few things
and then you're good to go so inside of
this we just need to provide few things
provided
dot
draggable props so earlier we put this
thing
droppable props but over here we're
gonna put the draggable props and
another things
we're going to add drag handle props and
of course we need to provide the ref so
that it can control it properly
yup just like that now if we go to our
browser and let's add something
and if i
grab it you can see
it's working but there's some issue over
here so if i go on and grab this
you can see this this thing is
levitating in the air
why is this happening
also see if we go over here it rests
over here but then goes to its original
position so if i go on and make this
like this it's not saving the state so
we need to add this logic so we're going
to add this logic later but first we
need to take care of this thing why is
this levitating in the air
so to fix this
we're going to go to our to do's list
and
right over here we're going to add
something called provider provided
dot placeholder
and similarly we're gonna add this
over here as well
just like that now if i go on and grab
this
yup you can see it's it produces an
empty placeholder for that item so if i
go on over here you can see it's
providing us the space to be dropped on
cool but still but it's still not saving
the state so let's go on and write the
logic for that
so if i go on to our app.tsx you might
remember this on drag function on drag
end function so i'm going to create this
function now
so let's remove this
and const on drag on drag end
and let's add this function right over
here
now this on drag ends sends this a
parameter called a result so we're going
to take result parameter
and result parameter will be of type
drop results now draw drop results so if
you're coding in javascript you don't
need to do this obviously but in
typescript you do
so
drop result
and you can see
and you can see it has imported that
from react beautiful dnd and now let's
see what is inside of this result
variable so let's go and log this so
result and let's go to our browser open
the console and if i go on and drag and
drop it
yeah you can see we got something so
let's explore this inside of this we
have two fields first for destination
and other for source so what is source
source is something where it came from
for example if it came from over here so
it's going to give this that okay it has
an index of zero in this array so it was
on index of zero and destination has
where where i dropped it so i dropped it
over here so it's going to have at the
index of one so it went to index of one
in this particular
area so how do we identify in which area
are we so remember we provided it
droppable
id so it's gonna tell us it was in the
droppable id it was dropped in the
droppable id and it was taken from the
to-do's list so if i go on and take this
and drop this over here
you're gonna see
the source is
to do's list and the destination is to
do is remove so yeah this is how we're
going to implement our logic so let's
find out so we're gonna take out both of
these things from result so
result and we're gonna take out
source and
destination now what are we going to do
with it first of all we're gonna check
if there's no destination if the
destination variable is empty how is
that gonna happen if i if we take this
and wait let me just first log it
yeah so if i take this and just leave it
over in the empty space so you're gonna
see
destination is null so if the
destination is null we don't have to do
anything so if
destination
doesn't exist so we're just gonna return
it
otherwise second use case will be if we
take this and we drop it in the same
position so if the source and the
destination are same then also we're
gonna do nothing so if destination
dot
dropable id
is equal to
source dot dropable id and it's in the
same index so i'm gonna copy this up
paste this and instead of droppable id
write index so if it's in the same index
as well so return
great so these were our base cases so
after this we're gonna declare a
variable called add
and we're gonna declare two more
variables first one will be active which
will have all of the to do's in the to
do's list state in this state so
we're gonna add it over here and the
other one will be complete
which is going to have all of the
completed to do's inside of it
yeah just like that now why have i
assigned it to this active why can't we
just directly manipulate it so again
when we have manipulated our active
variable we are going to provide it to
our set to do state so that will be a
more neat way to do this so now we're
going to check from where it came from
so we're going to first check the source
and we're going to take it from that
particular source so if first of all
we're going to check if it came from to
do's list dropable id so source
dot dropable id if it's equal to
to do's list then what are we going to
do
inside of this add variable we're gonna
take that particular thing so
active
and it was in the index of source dot
index right so we're gonna take source
dot index it we're gonna take it from
the source dot index
and then we are going to remove it from
that particular place
so active
dot slice i mean splice so you can see
over here splice is used to manipulate
the arrays remove or add inside of the
array so we're going to go to source dot
index and we are going to remove it
remove one item from that place that is
that item which we have taken in the ad
now we are going to do this similarly
for to do is remove as well so else to
do is remove so if it was in the
complete it came from over there so
we're going to take it from the complete
and when i remove it from there okay
cool so we have taken that particular to
do now we need to add it to the
destination
so similarly we're going to check if so
let me just copy this up
so if the source.dropable id is to-do's
list then what are we going to do
active
dot splice so now we're going to add it
inside of this array okay
so where do we need to add it we need to
add it destination.index now since we
are not removing anything so we're just
gonna say zero don't remove anything but
what are we doing we are adding it so
we're gonna say add this add variable
that we took from over here we're gonna
add it over here
copy this up and paste it over here and
instead of active we're gonna write
complete and now that we have
manipulated both of these variables now
we're going to add it to our state so
set
completed to do's we're going to have is
going to have complete
and set to do's is going to have active
now this should work if everything seems
fine yep looks good let's go ahead and
try it
if i take it and drop it over here
okay something went wrong clearly
oh for adding this we need to add this
for over here we need to write
destination not the source
because we're checking for the
destination right
let's go back and try to drop it yep
it's working absolutely fine
so you see how easy it is to implement
drag and drop in our react.js
applications but wait i need to do one
more thing
so if i
pick it up i should see some indicator
that it's in the drag mode or if we
hover on this this should glow up and if
i hover on this this particular part
should glow up so let's provide that i'm
gonna go to my code and inside of my to
do's list component
so i told you there's one more parameter
that it takes and that is a snapshot
so we're gonna take this snapshot and
let's go to our class names and i'm
going to wrap this in this
curly braces and provide this template
string so that we can write js inside of
it
and i'm going to open this curly braces
and write
snapshot dot is dragging over so if it's
dragging over this
then provided the class name of drag
active
otherwise
don't provide it any class names
similarly we're gonna do this to our
completed as well so
add backticks
and
comma snapshot
snapshot is dragging over then drag
remove
or probably drag complete
let's go ahead and add css for both of
these inside of our styles
i'm just gonna make the background color
a little bit more intense so if you go
on if i pick this up you can see if i
hover on this it's gonna glow if i have
around this this is going to glow
just like this and i want to increase
the shadow of this to do as well when
it's grabbed by me so
if i go on and go to our single to do
again we also have the snapshot here as
well
and with these to do single
i'm gonna add another class
so snapshot
dot is dragging
so
over there it was is dragging over
so and over here it's is dragging
so we're gonna provide it the class name
of drag otherwise we're not going to
provide any class name
and let's add these styles for it i'm
gonna add some intense back background
shadow i'm in box shadow
so in 20 pixels earlier it was 15 pixels
if you remember
so if i grab this you're gonna see the
shadow has gotten a little bit intense
awesome so you see how easy it is to
implement drag and drop in our react.js
applications i would love to see the
projects that you guys make after
learning this so thank you all for
watching this video if you like this
video just give this video a huge fat
thumbs up and don't forget to subscribe
to the channel just go to youtube.com
slash roadside coder and click on the
subscribe button it motivates me to
create more such awesome videos for you
guys